let's take a look at the text chain here
uh 10 43 A.M
on a Monday Glenn Howerton we should
start a bit earlier if we can we usually
take at least 75 minutes with
commercials can we start at 8 45
Charlie Day yeah I can get there then
Rob mcelhaney 845 Works exclamation
point well it's 8 45
uh Rob
Glenn
Megan
there's nobody here
there's nobody
left at the podcast
this this is it it's it's fizzled down
to nothing
well now Rob how do you feel about the
fact that Glenn was the one who said
well let's start at A45
I totally agree and uh Megan you're
you said you weren't going to be here
that's fair well
um
the gang wrestles for the trip what a
show guys
you know what a show like how does how
does Mark Maron do it I wonder you know
he just goes on and on and on by himself
oh wait a second we have an arriver
we have a
we have someone in the house and he's
not even going to get the most razzed
oh yeah buddy
yeah I could sing a funny little song
but I'm not in the mood my spirit is
crushed you know people are trying to
get to work they're trying to be
entertained
you know they're up with their morning
coffee
they need more they need more
we got to give them stuff you know
[Music]
yeah this is this is not something you
want to do alone right well now you
demanded we'd be here by this time and I
will say you were one minute late
which is fine yeah yeah yeah yeah I uh I
thought I was gonna be I thought it was
going to be worse than that and it was a
total oversight where's this man well
that's a very good question I don't know
I'm I I'm a little concerned uh because
he's not one to be late generally
speaking oh okay all right okay okay
I thought a voice I know
that's crazy I've been sitting out for
15 minutes reading my email because
Glenn said he was gonna be late
no no I swear to God no no no yes
unacceptable I've been here since 8 15.
oh well you haven't you really screw
yourself I haven't been here yeah you've
been in an Alleyway when I get when I
get a text that says hey guys I'm gonna
be late
I just go okay well then he's going to
be late so listen yeah yeah but I didn't
know how late he didn't say hello and it
was very on you I would have figured you
would have been early to give him a
little remember
it was his idea I was like you know I
sat here like a dick with my dick in my
hands I got this text and thought nah
but it could have been that could
potentially be fun but I'm sure the
audience has got to be sick of hearing
out one or two of us is late for the
show that they want to watch do you
think we'll cut that what's uh she's not
here uh uh what's on that piece of paper
there that's in front of you these are
like questions if someone wanted oh
that's where I usually sit she yeah she
gave me the host questions but that's
going to be you today Rob I guess gang
wrestles for the troops holy moly did
you watch it did you see it did you
enjoy it I watched it oh my God I
enjoyed it very very much yeah yeah
there's a level of silliness to that one
yeah that's just pure joy gotta feel
like we blew it I feel like we should
have bumped it up so that it was uh
airing on so that we were dropping it on
Memorial day but instead we're recording
the episode about wrestling for the
troops the day after the day after
Memorial Day so that's but I mean you
know I guess that's a thing but driving
it on Memorial Day would have been sweet
well when people listening to podcasts
on while they're at their barbecues they
would have been like hold the [__]
party they just dropped oh hang on a
second guys a military-themed podcast
yeah on a military-themed holiday yeah
DJ was like
those jean shorts off it's getting wild
how many people you think we're wearing
jean shorts yesterday a lot oh a lot a
lot yeah a lot of jean shorts around the
pool yesterday the weather was wasn't
great here in Los Angeles so for
Memorial Day
I flew in I was in New York City I was
in New York City I'm fine what were you
doing
you know what are you doing there uh we
had a little get-together from my old
man
um who is now 80 years old wow yeah 80.
so 8-0 uh yeah he actually turned 80 in
January but we were like we'll all get
together in the spring yeah January I
don't have to go out there yeah it was
it was good yeah it was lovely you know
family friends did you do anything else
see a show while you're out there no in
and out pal
in and out okay so you didn't you didn't
watch anything I'm trying to think if I
have a really
I don't no we watched um antidote
yeah if you had a really interesting
antidote I would definitely be want to
hear about that this the added C it's a
sneaky C it's a sneaky sneaky anecdote
anecdote
it's not that's not what I was trying to
say
now if you come back from New York
a really good antidote for her if you're
in your New York ales what else yeah
yeah uh season five episode seven gang
wrestles for the troop aired October
29th 2009 fellas uh it was written by
Scott martyr Rob Roselle and directed by
Randall Einhorn Randall Einhorn all over
this season special guest stars Travis
Schultz this is as Ben the soldier this
is Travis's first episode with us yes
first appearance of Roddy Piper as the
maniac yes yes that's right he's been on
twice because he was selling yeah
and Don Frye as a wrestling opponent huh
okay now I'm glad that that was I'm glad
that that was fun
so right I I watched the episode
yesterday and it jumped out at me as
soon as the the episode began that Don
Frye
is up Don fry is a pioneer
of all of the UFC he is one of the
original like when hoist Gracie was when
he he was around that era well so like
the early early years yeah really early
in terms of he was fighting or he was
like let's build a business called the
UFC he was fighting oh listen Hey listen
if he had started that [__] business
he wouldn't have been wrestling for us
on It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
yeah he'd be sitting in his mansion
somewhere people love what they do well
yeah we none of us were UFC fans at the
time no I remember do you guys remember
that was when UFC was like this is my
memory of it at least and you guys tell
me if you remember this too it was
advertised on TV it was like VHS tapes
you could yeah I remember the mail in
college watching a VHS voice Grace and
it was brutal so people getting their
arms broken like it was it was like it
was it was basically like cage like
blood sports stuff with the long beard
who's kind of like heavyset it was like
tank the tank yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Tank Abbott take Abbott yeah David tank
yeah all right from Huntington Beach
I remember him okay would you have the
playing cards what's happening right now
okay I'll trade you a Tank Abbott for a
hoist Gracie so none of us were into the
UFC at that time or when we shot this
episode in 2009 but by 2009 the UFC was
was was doing pretty well off yeah uh
but we didn't realize that that
um that Don Frye was this Pioneer of the
UFC and so I've subsequently I've become
a big fan I've gone back and watched all
of those early UFC events all of them
I've seen everyone in the first 20 where
does this man find the time what if I if
I'm working out or something like that
it's a good thing to pop on because wait
a minute anyway you've got UFC in the
background while you're working out and
you're actually paying attention you're
like that's that's Don Frye I've been
doing a seller
you don't have to watch like you know
you can it's not like uh yeah a film
with subtitles you can look away from
the screen that's a beautiful mind [__]
man where you can do two things at the
same time like you need
he needs to be concentrating on his form
or he's gonna hurt himself he's in his
40s I find it motivating
to watch that kind of Blood Sport sure
okay I'm sorry I interrupted please
continue were you annoyed by the fact
that I've found it inspiring I'm worried
about you I'm worried about your form
I'm worried about your form while you're
working out you gotta yeah
no between sets between sets you're
watching sets you're just looking up and
you're saying you've seen some sweaty
men and you're turning yourself into a
sweaty man and you're seeing another
sweaty man you want to be sweating like
him sweat here and then you're watching
it on the menu if there was another man
in here for me to press against that
would be exciting and then I don't know
well if there was a man I I wouldn't
want to press against it would be Don
fry Don fry was was uh was famous for he
was a wrestler and it was like a
Collegiate American yes Collegiate he
was a wrestling coach at I believe
Arizona State he was also a firefighter
and this was at a time where you were
semi-professional you were a fighter but
you were also like you had a job oh you
had to but he he was one of those guys
that came in early and was able to
compete and I believe he beat hoyce
Gracie if he did he was around that are
you serious yeah Mark Coleman I believe
there's there's a fight between Don fry
and Mark Coleman that's one of the most
brutal things that's ever been caught on
on videotape what brutal what happens
they savagely beat the living [__] out
of each other that still happens what I
what I what I never saw and never wanted
to see was am I am I crazy in thinking
that in the really really early days of
UFC they had a lot less rules
a lot fewer rules uh Meg was here she
she would point that out uh yes Jesus
there is a lot less rules okay fine a
lot fewer a lot fewer roles yes you
could and you could you could break
there was groin yeah right you couldn't
put there was no eye gouging no eye
gouging uh but that was kind of it I
mean you could snap people's limbs if
you wanted to right you can still do
that if people don't tap out yeah
they'll break your people's arms get
broken and things like that I know but
that they that yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
it's pretty sad yeah but there's things
like you could could you like back in
the day I mean can you just straight up
kick somebody in their knee and just
buckle their knees you can do that now
yeah just break somebody yeah they have
yeah they have rules against elbows your
elbows can only come at a certain angle
across someone's face which seems very
specific yeah it's worth it well they
don't want you they don't want you
uppercutting they don't want you getting
that you know the bone into the into the
brain thing is that just a is that a
real thing is that a real way to kill
somebody to get their nose bone go into
their brain or is that just one of those
urban legends because you don't really
hear about that happening I've never
heard of that yeah do you think that
that would happen in boxing from time to
time yeah you think yeah you'd be like
people just like trip and hit their nose
on a table and like went up in your
brain and you died yeah it's worth
having uh Meg uh when she comes back to
work
um put up some of that UFC footage from
an early fight there was a there was one
in particular I'm thinking of with this
guy named uh Joe San and joseon was on
the ground and there was a guy that he
was fighting who was just
hounding
on his dick
I mean just pounding on it until
eventually he tapped
groin strikes yeah yeah that was legal
that would be an amazing thing too if
like if that was like your signature
move you know what I mean like just just
like pounding dick yeah yes Johnny Dix
you know in the ring and the Octagon was
in an octagon back then I think that
came in later it was definitely it was a
hexagon or maybe it could have been
Square oh if it was a square that's just
you know that's a mess
um so so don Frost Don Frye and I I was
very struck by it because at the time he
was just a guy that Roddy was wrestling
who was
did Don fry also wrestle in the WWF
maybe maybe
hmm okay all right his nickname was the
predator
yeah he looked he had like a predator
look yeah
yeah okay yeah I remember him now
remember him now okay well should we
talk about the episode I would I'd love
to this I'd love to it's so funny so
funny Roddy Piper man I mean we could
just talk about him if there are people
under the age of 35 watching or
listening to this they can't really
fully understand the cultural impact
that Roddy Piper had yeah so for us like
wrestling was what Tick-Tock is now you
know or YouTube it was like it was our
stories it was our soap opera yeah
little bits of information it's not a
full narrative
Zenith yeah you could argue right in the
late 80s yeah the late 1980s
it's been big for yeah maybe we were at
our Zenith yeah yeah
when you hit 12 euros I don't know I
mean Hulk Hogan Andre the Giant coffee
beware
Tito Santana Rowdy Roddy Piper yeah iron
Chic the iron cheeks
rice sakes George The Animal Steele
Randy's Randy The Hitman savage or no
Randy no Randy Macho Man Randy
and steroids were like
just you know Finding their sweet spot
of like we can really juice a guy up
yeah look what we do to this Mantra man
yeah we'll turn him into a yeah wanna
see how Macho we can make this guy he's
more Macho than that look at his
sunglasses
it's like a windshield but the
characters that those guys created I
mean yeah you go back and still you
watch fantastic fantastic oh yeah Macho
Man right the Savage is barely he is a
true Savage he's barely a person it's
great it's what happens when you're
living on Slim gems and steroids to what
extent is it fake is it real they keep
it I think they take umbrage with the
word fake because it is and we kind of
addressed this in the episode it's not
fake insofar as they are putting their
bodies through that oh yeah it's just
that it's choreographed it's certainly
to an extent right because you can kind
of wing have signals though you know
when they do like the that you know
they're like indicating to each other
they're like you know like slapping
stuff and they're like okay now he's
gonna do the thing like yeah there's
little codes right that they throw yes I
I always thought when you hear that it's
that it's choreographed you have this
idea in mind that it's very it's very
rehearsed and before before the show
they've gone through all of the moves
and it kind of isn't that they figure
out who's going to win and then they
have a couple of moves that they know
they're going to do but and then
apparently Andre the Giant would just do
whatever he wanted and everybody had to
just go along with it and Roddy says in
his book I read his book oh yeah with
Piper in the piper I read that book he
talks about yeah it's amazing he talks
all over the place Andre
he talks about Andre
was so it didn't matter who was
wrestling Andre including Hulk Hogan and
Big John Stud and like massive man if
Andre wanted to pick you up and throw
you into Neptune he could really yes now
towards the end of his yeah he was
falling apart yeah he looked big but not
he was so strong they were saying like
the difference between muscle and just
like straight up Mass if somebody weighs
5 500 pounds it doesn't matter if you
weigh 300 pounds if you're Shaquille
O'Neal but if somebody weighs 200 pounds
more than you yeah you're picking up
Shaquille you're picking up Shaquille
O'Neal and you're throwing him yeah
that's wild yeah yeah imagine being able
to toss somebody as big as Hulk Hogan or
Randy Macho Man said well you think of
yourself as a grown man and you're like
well there's no other grown man there's
a there's a grown man there's very few
grown men that you think could actually
pick you up like like a child and just
throw you right but Shaq could do that
yeah absolutely because sure relative to
me yeah if you think about your child
like no matter what if your child came
at you with like punches you'd
eventually just grab one and throw him
across the street right you could do
that if you wanted to I would do that's
my child but I would do it to another
child if another child came at me I sure
did yeah I would toss it but if you
outweigh something by 150 pounds yeah
yeah you can right how tall was he we
know they list him at seven almost eight
feet tall which he was not I think he
was like seven five seven four seven
five yeah I mean there's NBA players
taller than him but not bigger than him
yeah but it's the tall it's the tall
with the big it's the tall with the big
those photos of him drinking a beer
and he was yeah he was eight eight feet
tall yeah I know he was taller than
eight feet he was he was like he was
like eight we need eight seconds we need
we need our our fact Checker because I
was actually just looking this up the
other day too because
I don't know miles was talking about it
he must have asked me last night who the
tallest man ever was yeah and it was
like well let's look at it Robert
waddling I'm gonna say he's eight six
the man himself was what eight nine
eight ten and eight eleven eleven almost
almost nine tall how how was he when he
died nine and two six was he 36 he had
to be very yeah oh wow 32.
oh no he was 22 years old when he died
because the gigantism yeah what's the
proper term is that what they call it
they probably don't call it that anymore
right because that's offensive cut that
cut that cut that cut that don't cut it
I cut that [__] Giants
they have it all
we used to be able to openly slay Giants
early man would slay a giant all right
you know slang Giants is very frowned
upon me I know you can't slay Giants
anymore back in mythological days anyone
yeah
um
oh man
but Roddy was the was the best so the
crazy thing about Roddy is if he's gonna
go and wrestle someone who's seven feet
tall or Hogan who's six six or something
like that six seven yeah Roddy was not
five eleven yeah and he had crossed over
into mainstream entertainment just a
little bit you know this was you know
the rock obviously did it best but like
Hogan kind of dabbled but no one ever
was like ah he's an actor you know
Schwarzenegger was kind of taking the
big guy roles you know for a big muscly
man but Roddy like had a couple
Indie movies that became like cult
classics they live primarily they live
um and he could act
okay so what I remember was when he
start when he came in
he was like there was some like method
acting [__] happening like he was in
character like he would he would I mean
he would interact with us but like he
was he was dating character he kind of
stayed in character to a degree and I
remember thinking at the time and I
think I brought this up to you guys like
he was so good and playing it so real
and so his performance was so haunted
that it was like I was watching him
thinking he could have played the
wrestler oh yeah
he's the wrestler he would have been
amazing he
think he work was incredible he kind of
would like say the lines you kind of
would say his own thing sometimes
remember and it was a little you had to
kind of dance around communicating with
him although he was nice but like he
didn't like give off the like hey we're
just gonna chit chat and hang I feel
like when he came back the second he did
yeah I mean he he when we were off the
stage in the dressing room so I spent a
lot of time talking to him he was a
completely different person yeah totally
yeah but but as soon as he got on set he
was kind of in the maniac yes it was the
Mania he was the Mania he was dumb
Maniac he had the most amazing Stories
the most amazing he well he told me he
survived a couple plane crashes
that uh they would like take these like
little puddle jumper planes so they
could like do as many wrestling shows
you know they would be like in Ontario
Canada and then they'd be like we're
just gonna pop over to some other little
town and we're gonna do a show really
quick and then like occasionally the
engines would drop out of these things
they said he like survived I think he
told me at least three plane crashes he
might have said five
but yeah he like walked away from them
like he had been stabbed by a fan
um or uh I don't know if you would call
somebody a fan who stabs you but he was
that
hey man
sorry to do this just a huge fan huge
fan well he would say that would go into
these markets and and Roddy always
played the heel because that's what he
was good at so he was always the guy
that everybody booed and like jeered and
people would be whipped up into a frenzy
and then they would truly believe that
this guy was like a bad bad guy yeah he
always played a bad guy and so some some
Maniac some crazy person at one of these
events just took out a knife and just
stabbed him a bunch of times yeah as he
was headed to the ring
how did he dispense with that guy did he
did he actually like did he get stabbed
do you remember did he tell you this
story yeah he got and it's in it's in
the book too he he got stabbed
um and then beat the [__] out of the guy
and then from that point forward he had
a pistol he had a pistol with him he
would he had a jacket he always wore a
jacket well that's it's the same jacket
he wore on the show yes that was his
jacket that was his jacket and he showed
me where he kept his pistol which he
kept it he still kept it yeah
to stop from the stabbings
foreign
a journey with a new friend who's always
with me one who saved my life oh boy
where is this going yeah is this is this
Mac talking or is this Rob talking what
I'm talking about is my journey
with electrolytes oh okay okay yeah all
right I'm happy to hear that yeah yeah
dude I'm talking about elements and
their electrolyte mix that's designed to
replenish what your body sweats out even
if you aren't an athlete like myself
okay so this is Mac talking element
contains a science-backed ratio of 1 000
milligrams sodium 200 milligrams
potassium and 60 milligrams magnesium
with no sugar no gluten no coloring and
nothing artificial oh okay so it's made
for everyone but it's extra helpful for
keto low carb and paleo diets that's
correct now can I tell you how elements
showed me the error of my sinful ways
and helped me turn it all around still
sounding like mac yeah okay just go
ahead okay no this is Rob because I
would dehydrate myself with Manhattans
not not work out and eat chimichangas
and donuts to cultivate mass now I was
no stranger to headaches muscle cramps
fatigue and sleeplessness but I looked
Within and I asked for help and also
Google my symptoms and boom element to
the rescue well hey look if it's good
enough for Olympic athletes Navy Seals
NBA NFL and NHL players it's good enough
for me you have officially converted us
right now element is offering our
listeners a free sample pack with any
purchase that's eight single serving
packets free with any element order now
this is a great way to try all eight
flavors and share element with a salty
friend get yours at drinkelement.com
Sunny now this deal is only available
through our link okay so you must go to
d r i n k l m n t.com slash Sunny
element lmnt offers no questions asked
refunds try it totally risk-free if you
don't like it share it with a salty
friend and they will give your money
back no questions asked you have nothing
to lose guys
uh guys where do we stand on our uh
Taylor Swift tickets oh we can't miss
her okay I got him no well as I was I
was in line for hours and I got nothing
you cannot get tickets these days no
look buying tickets does not have to be
stressful okay it's not stressful at all
if you use gametime.com oh right yes no
game time of course yeah no that that's
the app you use to find Flash Deals and
last minute tickets event you know for
any kind of event in in your area right
yeah and it doesn't have to be last
minute you know what I mean Taytay is
not here till August but I found some
some sick deals on on pit how good are
we talking about like with these seats
because I need to be close enough where
I can look into Taylor's eyes and see
when she sings All Too Well that she's
singing about Jake Gyllenhaal what do
you mean see if she's singing about Jake
chilling I need to definitely singing I
know but I need to know if she's feeling
it or if she's just checked out okay how
about row two buddy yeah that'll do as
long as I can afford them are they going
to be reasonably well let me tell you
something right now with a game time
guarantee you will always get the best
price now if you find tickets in the
same section uh and row for Less game
time will credit you
110 of the difference but in my
experience no one else can no one else
can compete anyway I might already have
a thing that night I gotta run it by
Jill you know luckily we can wait till
the day off because game time is the
place for last minute tickets
by in two seconds and then the tickets
come straight to your phone no print no
email nobody no crime snag the tickets
without the stress with Game Time
download the game time app create an
account and use code Sunny for twenty
dollars off your first purchase terms
apply again create an account and redeem
code Sunny for twenty dollars off
download game time today last minute
tickets lowest prices guaranteed
my favorite thing in this episode is the
happy accident do you guys know yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah so in the end Roddy
had a whole sort of monologue about how
much he loves us and he cares about us
and and the whoever was driving the
police car got the cue wrong so the car
just takes off it was like take one I
think
he's starting to say his monologue and
he goes no wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait he doesn't get to say his
monologue and it just wanted to be it
was so funny that was so much more real
right it's like the cop doesn't wait for
you to say your monologue and then drive
off right so like so is my memory wrong
because my memory of that is actually
that he didn't have a speech but he had
the idea to do a speech I think that's
actually I think he wanted to improvise
a speech and he told us and so we knew
he was going to do it that's but nobody
told the driver
so then that is absolutely exactly yes
yes
and we were you know we're like yeah go
ahead let's do it uh and no one had told
the driver so he started
and that is of course so much funnier
yeah
oh my boys my boys he grows very close
to us he thinks of us as his as his
children now you've talked about this on
an earlier podcast but I think it's
worth mentioning again that you had this
idea on the day that we were shooting
the scene where he pulls the razor wire
out of his car which was also not in the
scrape script I think we gave him a
bunch of props and then he he came up
with the idea I think of like of pulling
the razor wire out now it was his head
he would do like a wrestling bit like
yeah it would get you in the balls
that's like the crowd loves that oh yes
right right he was like bringing a
wrestling bit Yeah yeah by the way I
love how I love how real you play that
and I love you play it till the end of
the scene like you just it's not it
never doesn't hurt I was thinking like I
was like watching I was like I should
have played it a little bit in the next
thing but we might have shot the cricket
scene before we decided to do the
railway maybe you had the the uh idea of
when we ask him about his kids that he
goes hey dress up goes really dark and
he goes really haunted and you don't
know what happened to his kids and that
leaves us reeling like
did this guy kill his kid did this did
he kill his kids what happened to his
kids yeah
guys like you you know what I love you
guys man you know you you remind me of
my kids oh you got kids maniac
what does that mean
all right
okay all right we got a problem I don't
know what what is he talking about with
his kids kill his kids he just drifted
away he nails that delivery yeah you see
his it's so real it's so real he goes he
really goes there something sad has
happened he's lost he's lost touch with
his his children now did Brody have
children and really he does he yeah yeah
he's got he's got a son I know for sure
and a daughter and I worked with his
daughter I directed a commercial with um
Ronda Rousey and she was fighting
somebody was it was Rod's daughter
really yeah he was in uh W she might be
in the WWE that's awesome I miss Roddy I
really he was great he's great he's a
great guy he was a great guy he was and
a great actor I do love this trend of
ours though of um and I have tremendous
respect for Comedians and comedic actors
but I do love that we
have this trend of like wanting to get
dramatic performers on our show you know
like like it was always funny funnier to
us I mean even initially when we were
you know going over uh people that could
possibly play
you know Dennis and D's dad
that we were talking about Ray Liotta uh
that we were talking about um Ray Liotta
was number one Ray Liotta was that was
the that was our our number one that was
before Danny came yeah when we were just
knocking around the ideas yeah we were
like wow Ray Liotta would be amazing
imagine rayleota as frankly it would
have been incredible it's a completely
different it's a totally different
character a totally different show uh I
my character probably wouldn't ever have
gotten as angry because Ray Liotta would
have taken that role yeah the show would
have been great
hey no Danny yeah the only Danny can do
it you know that only Ray can do what
Ray does yeah but you know and that's
that's that's the thing but but I liked
I I've always kind of gravitated towards
that I really enjoy watching dramatic
actors give dramatic performances in a
comedy where the situation and the
character and the want is so crazy that
that's what makes it funny and the
performance itself is very grounded and
real I love that well speaking of drama
the wonderful dramatic scene of deciding
what our team name is going to be yeah
and what what they're what what how we
describe what they are and US basically
just describing Birds to you when I was
watching this episode uh yesterday I
wanted to watch those outtakes because I
remember them being very funny and
there were some notable
missing things and I don't know why I
remember this but I remember we went on
a lot of different riffs about a lot of
different wrestlers you did a whole bit
about cocoa beware you did a whole bit
about the Junkyard Dog yeah yeah yeah
yeah I remember you doing a bunch of
riffing on on a bunch of different
wrestlers and I remember just crying
laughing at all all that I was big into
wrestling so yeah so was I well in that
particular era I was as well so all the
that's why it was so funny to me because
I knew all the wrestlers that you were
referencing but had like yeah you kind
of forget about forgotten about it you
would do like this neighborhood Royal
Rumbles in my buddy's basement where we
would like move the chairs and oh yeah
into like oh yeah and then the last man
standing in the middle wins yes and so
the move usually was like gang up on the
biggest kid first like everyone go out
for the biggest kid get him out of the
ring right smart and then we can that's
what they that's what they would do in
the Royal Rumble yeah they would go
after Andre first
yeah slowly but surely you just really
learned from the best you never know
who's going to wind up you never know
you leave that giant in the ring
Anything Can Happen yeah so slay the
giant first again I you know Chinese
silken hair who came up with that Rob
Roselle Rob Roselle right now like a hot
dog
now Roddy had a great head of hair yeah
sure he did all the way till the end
there yeah yeah how old was he when he
passed
yeah maybe 60 but I don't know yeah
hard living yeah his book that
the book is worth checking out in the
pit with Piper I do remember just being
absolutely blown away at the stories
that he was telling and it's and it is
literally just a collection of stories
like it's all over the place there's no
narrative it's like being in his head he
just jumps all over the place but the
stories the anecdotes
are really fun the antidotes to boredom
yes it's the antidote at the boredom the
scene where we meet Ben and he comes off
that bus okay first of all Caitlyn is
great in that scene as desert rose and
she looks so damn funny the costume this
episode yeah is amazing so on the nose
everything she's doing she look she
dressed like a rose she brought a rose
she's gonna sing Desert Rose yeah she's
going to sing
and then she runs off
and Danny okay now this is the
difference between one of the radio or a
dramatic actor versus a comedic actor
where Danny doesn't say anything as he's
as he's playing the song and he's just
looking or even as she's trying to think
yes
he like does like a noise he's like and
then he pushes the button then he's like
yeah he's looking at her like huh that
scene too like and then he presents some
jean shorts and he kind of drapes them
and he like salutes them the kind of
thing that is what I feel like would be
so misunderstood by anyone who wasn't a
sunny fan or had it like if you just
watched that scene for the first time
you're like well this isn't funny these
guys are going for something it's just
not working but when you know the show
and you know the tone and you've lived
with it for years it is the funniest
yeah on paper you're like
that's the kind of thing that people are
like why why is this
like if you showed someone that scene
for the first time you're like so this
is the show they'd be like huh
jean shorts and saluting a man well okay
so let's stop down for a second because
I get asked this question quite a bit
and I I don't know what the answer is
maybe we can figure it out on this
podcast there are definitely episodes
when someone says I've never seen your
show
uh but I but I want to start because I
hear I've heard enough about it where
should I start I never I just tell them
not to watch it because they're probably
not going to get it but what's the
episode to where you where you begin and
I definitely know the episodes where you
shouldn't begin let's get the pilot
don't start with the first one well I I
was watching it yesterday and Caitlyn I
paused it for a second to come into the
kitchen and I was laughing and she's
like I can hear you laughing in the
other room what are you laughing about
and I was laughing at how the show is so
specific it's so specific and this
episode is so specific and I can see why
if you if you like it you would love it
because it's very Niche and specific and
if you don't like it I can also
understand why you wouldn't like it and
this episode in particular
it feels like to your point Charlie you
have to know the show so well to get so
much of it I think
but I think I'm I am always of the
mindset that
you just have to
make that like you you have a vision for
a thing and a voice and you just [__]
stick to it and they'll either come
around to it or they won't
they may never or they it may come late
like a lot of people just didn't get or
understand our show and they all now
kind of were like well yeah that show is
great maybe around the time that we were
doing that scene the people who were
already in loved it the people who
didn't know would be like I don't know
what the [__] this show is yeah like
dressing like birds and handing someone
jean shorts why is this funny
um
but then like over time the people who
are going to come around to it really
appreciate the fact that you get so
specific right and then the people who
are never gonna get are just never gonna
get it but if we were like yeah we can't
really do this scene we got to do
something that reaches a wider audience
it would kill the show I don't know
that's what art is right you just gotta
[__] but it's great when you can do
both right it's amazing if you can yeah
if you can pull off both yeah that's uh
that's the that's the Sweet Spot yeah
but sometimes you can't
sometimes you gotta hand someone jean
shorts and salute them and see what
happens that's it and talk about desert
roses and desert grapes the casting of
Travis I mean Travis every once in a
while we'll write something and then you
go through the audition process and you
see people come in and every once in a
while someone will just come in and nail
it and you're like yep that's the one
and you can't imagine anyone else being
the character you're like well that's
the guy
it feels so good to finally hold you oh
you you're you're riding my lip hi oh
let it go with a coincidence
oh you're the girl from the bus stop yes
I am well you guys are friends right not
really
tell your friend thanks for the shorts
they've been great yeah will do so
what's
what's the deal with you standing I
thought there was a wheelchair and you
were in it oh no no I I twisted my knee
getting off a plane in Germany uh I'm I
was just trying to stay off of it good
enough
it's so great because he's nothing like
that in real life he's nothing like that
really but he knows exactly what's funny
about him yeah you know to come in he's
he's handsome and he kind of has that
just that that quality that he can turn
off and on where he's just sort of sweet
and dim-witted and he's very sweet in
real life but he's certainly not dim
with it no he just knows exactly what's
funny about him yeah yeah that's why
we've gone back to the well with him so
many times yeah the Travis well where
did the jean shorts thing come from
talked about it and in the uh
the Extreme Makeover episode about I was
wearing longer jean shorts and you had
the cutoffs and you could do the great
legs right so we already had already
done a jean short bit but Roselle just
has an obsession with jean shorts I
think right yeah that's right so yeah
and then we got we you know we hit it
again with Chad later where he was like
you gotta take the teen shorts off
because you're gonna blow once we
established once we established Ben the
soldier wearing those jean shorts in
this episode and being like they fit
great that was it for him that was his I
think we've only ever seen his character
no he's we've probably seen him in
something else since then but mostly
he's been in jean shorts yeah if he was
in something else it was it was for a
very specific reason but yeah he just
kind of continued to wear those jean
shorts and and uh and our character Z
had to you know had to let him know that
you do have to take them off every now
and then it's a funny like plot too do
you think we would think of that plot
today to be like we're gonna
do a wrestling match it was so labored
and I remember it being labored in the
in the writer's room yeah we knew we
wanted to do something with wrestling
how do we get into it how can we justify
it it's clunky as hell
I mean yeah we don't really justify the
motivation there's something about maybe
us being younger too where you still
just kind of buy these guys want to put
on like a wrestling match like yeah and
it feels like maybe the characters are
too old for that [__] now
it's always I
don't know I mean you got
you got Roddy yeah you got Roddy telling
telling us you know he's like you know
you kids uh he's calling us kids and
stuff and like back then that didn't
even like didn't even fully occur to me
that even then we weren't kids because
in my mind I still was a kid even though
I was in my 30s yeah you know the
characters certainly were well maybe it
works because Charlie says we'll do this
to celebrate America
we'll do it to celebrate the troops
maybe celebrate ourselves a little bit
and that's when we're really good on
board yeah that's more like that's
that's a lot of good things but
especially the celebrating us
foreign
[Music]
sponsored by betterhelp that's right
Charlie better help is an online therapy
service that dares ask the question how
much time are you spending on other
people in a given week versus how much
time you're spending on yourself that's
right it's very easy to get caught up
with what everybody needs from you and
you never take a moment to really reel
it in and just be selfish they're not a
good kind of selfish right
self-preserving because otherwise we
spend all our time giving and we end up
feeling depleted and and burned out but
therapy can give you the tools you know
to strike that sweet sweet balance in
your life you know so you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind no hesitation no
surrender no man Left Behind that's
right now we know Meg has tried better
help in the past and she always talks
about how beneficial it was to her where
is Meg today uh well maybe she had a
better health appointment she might have
oh okay well hey good for you Meg good
for you prioritizing yourself and your
health over others demands we love a
good boundary better help is entirely
online and it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist that's all you got to
do and you can switch up your therapist
anytime faux free so if you're thinking
about starting therapy don't overthink
it just do it at betterhelp.com fine
more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com sunny today and get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
help.com
sunny
[Music]
all right all right okay at the top of
this recording we are days away from the
start of the NBA finals and by the time
this airs we'll be two games in both
teams will be tied 1-1 or someone will
be up to zero statistics
and who is that going to be well who's
to say man you know but we should
probably figure that out because the
books are open baby no I mean literally
like who's playing
two basketball teams the Denver Nuggets
and the Miami Heat ah and your money is
on well that's up to you Glenn whichever
team you believe in but you should place
your bets on DraftKings Sportsbook an
official sports betting partner of the
NBA now new customers can place a five
dollar bet and score 200 bucks in bonus
bets instantly plus all customers can
take a shot at even bigger payouts with
DraftKings stepped up same game parlays
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and use the code always so just get on
to DraftKings Sportsbook and flip a coin
and think about how much you can win if
you have a gambling problem call 1-800
Gambler in Massachusetts call
1-800-327-5050 or visit
gamblinghelplinema.org in New York call
8778 Hope NY or text Hope NY
467369 now if you're in Kansas you're
going to want to call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort Kansas 21 plus in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
apply see draftkings.com Sportsbook for
details and state-specific responsible
gambling resources bonus bets expire or
seven days after issuance opt in at 10
plus leg Rec for a 100 boost eligibility
wagering and deposit restrictions apply
terms at sportsbook.com draftkings.com
basketball terms
[Music]
here's a question from Megan besides
missing a tooth Cricket looks okay at
the start of this episode it ends up
with his first major injury that starts
his physical decline do you already did
we already have that journey in mind for
him is that right
um I think no we didn't have any sort of
a journey in mind for him but uh he
already bashes legs up good uh in yes uh
he'd gotten his legs bashed up by the
gangsters but yes he is he is relatively
clean cut when we go see him at the
Men's Shelter
um some great outtakes from that scene
as well
um
let's throw up those up those outtakes
now
how do you find me
laughs
this is not no this is not a suck joint
this is an adult men's Rehabilitation
Center an adult center that's the point
we're trying to make we can read between
them
his sand move yeah he had a he had a
specific idea of what the sand was going
to be yeah I liked it too I liked it I
liked his uh I liked his style what are
we doing with the sand were we what was
he blowing into our face I don't know
because he really was blowing something
right yeah so I don't and and it looked
like we were really getting hit with it
for for sure so yeah I don't know what
we would have been okay with it was
definitely around the time where it
would have been something that that
Glenn would have been like wait wait can
we talk about what this is and you and I
would be like shut up just do it just do
it yeah and it might have been like
asbestos no it wouldn't have been but if
it was 1975 Charlie and I would have
been the same people and you would have
been like well can we talk about what it
is we're breathing in and Charlie would
be like we we'd be like dude stop being
a [__] just [__] do it yeah yeah and
then meanwhile you're getting you
visited us in our hospital rooms yeah
remember how about Danny as the trash
man what's your memory of this do you
remember he seemed to he enjoy it yeah I
feel like he liked being in that onesie
he kills it in this episode top to
bottom I mean when he when he's you know
when he first comes out as a trash man
first of all I love the old school yeah
the whole thing
now there's a great look and the
character was kind of in that zone where
George was not really supposed to be he
was a part animal yeah was it his thing
chewing on your head he would know he
would eat the turnbuckle oh that's it he
would chew the turnbuckle because he was
he was a beast yeah he was a beast
I don't know what they were selling what
they were selling there was he was like
raised in the uh in the jungle I don't
know but he would eat it was a barbarian
type situation right and he was raised
in a basement which I've since the last
time we spoke you saw about it I enjoyed
but uh so yeah maybe he was like they
finally let him out from the basement of
the right and he didn't know not to chew
the turbo no because he was raised by
yeah everything was food as far as he
was concerned if I could get it in my
mouth yeah turnbuckles especially sure
and according to the the the stories
that you might find in in the pit with
Piper there there is some truth to some
of the characters like people didn't
want to hang out with George Animal
Steele because he was really like
deranged yeah I mean no he might not be
eating turnbuckles and it is off time
but it was like that guys keep that guy
keep him at a distance now before Vince
McMahon sort of turned it into a mega
business or whatever was there another
guy who was his father his father ran
and it was like it was like
yeah yeah
it was super Regional they had like this
the southern belt and then they had the
Canadians Canadian yeah so a lot of it
was like North America and then there
was a wasn't there a WCW am I making
that up yeah and then they just started
consolidating them which probably had as
much to do with how television worked at
the time right Vince is the one
Consolidated everything but like Ric
Flair was in a completely different
organization and then
it was it was like a more Regional a lot
of Ric Flair stories in in Roddy's book
yeah a lot of Jake The Snake stories in
Roddy's book Jake The Snake who became a
governor right no no no no no no
Jake The Snake no no no no they're
different guys similar look similar very
similar look yes although Jake The Snake
didn't have the body so Jesse Ventura
had a like a ripped body Jake never
really
he was big and he had a snake he was
tall he had long hair did he not yeah he
had a mullet yeah mullet in a mustache
yeah and not a great body but huge
probably like six five or something yeah
and a maniac of a person also in real
life and he what he didn't carry that
snake around yeah and then he would
knock you out and then he would take the
ball constrictor and just put it on your
body and for some reason that would
cause you to foam at the mouth there was
no science
the fact that they were torturing this
poor snake and bring it into them
wrestling imagine when do I get to eat
one of these guys yeah yeah Am I Ever
Gonna actually get to finish off one of
these guys it was what was the name of
the snake Clementine or something like
that yeah the snake had a name yeah I
don't know sure sure
yeah I don't know so wait then Ric Flair
was a god which was a hero he was like
he was like a yeah who was like the hype
man guy with like the magnet
yeah and Bobby The Brain Heenan he was
also
in and then there were like the no-name
guys that like would come in and wrestle
like and then this week you're wrestling
yeah but it was it's cool to kind of
track how some some guys would start as
no-name people and then they would
transition
yeah like Macho Man started off off I
believe is leaping leaping Lenny poffo
and then he had like a completely yeah
was also a pretty good name and then he
and then he just transitioned into a
different character I Believe Jimmy
Superfly Snuka oh Jimmy so Jimmy
simplify snooka got got almost killed by
Roddy
almost killed him
these coconuts uh I thought your head
was coconut-like and it could take it
you know coconut on a coconut yeah
yeah now my head is not made of coconut
Rottie coconuts together one of them's
gonna break yeah you don't know which
ones so that's the I think that's the
rub when people say it's fake like it's
not it's not fake it's just that when
you hit somebody with it over the head
with a coconut and you don't pull the
punch a little bit it's Gonna Knock his
It's Gonna Knock him unconscious
like a rib kick that seems pretty real
in the in the I'm sure we add a little
sound effect but boy it seems like the
foot hits the river I mean these guys
were so hopped up on painkillers because
they were getting hurt yeah like left
and right drinking like an Advil
smoothie in the morning yeah just 65
Advils yeah just a Vicodin and a bottle
of vodka you know a pint of vodka and
just yeah that's what's up the song The
the birds of War
um
we must have put that beat in in post we
did and yeah we did never matched up
because we didn't have the we didn't
have the [__] earwigs we needed that
you needed to have you got to have the
earwigs to to stay on beat otherwise
you're gonna speed up or slow down you
know and it's a bummer we could have
just had somebody going and post and
literally like slow down and speed up
with us yeah you know but uh you know
this was season five so I guess we
weren't doing that I mean you know
edited by Tim roach I recognized his
voice he's the uh the announcer yeah
yeah the big picture though I love this
I love this season yeah I love this
season it just uh was a great time of
our lives I do think that we'd really
hit our stride in this season I remember
thinking it at the time
um it still feels to me like
two three and four we were still
tweaking it and finding it there's great
great great episodes in those Seasons
but like season five feels like where we
really found it the the the scene of
delivering him the shorts feels like the
kind of thing you can only do when you
feel as though you've found your voice
right and you're like we know what our
voice is we feel confident to just sit
with Danny and this song and that this
is entertaining enough for the for who
we're trying to entertain the painted
ABS last thing
when did that was that in the script or
did we I remember asking Leo votra to do
that and just do it and then that was
one of those where you were like I don't
know if we should do this and I was like
Leo just just paint it on just paint it
on and you were like I don't know we
should talk about it and I was like just
just stop just stop and then nine times
out of ten you do that I do that and
then I get to the end of it and I'm like
I just erase it but I did it and then
you looked at it and you're like okay
I'll do that yeah that's funny it's so
funny yeah yeah even the just the the
costumes just the Hat
the feathers on the shoulders that's you
know that like we'll we'll describe it a
little bit but then the classroom
department has to go and make it and
like between desert rose and that bird
costume and and the trash trash man and
the Taliban and Taliban they just really
knocked it out of the park total episode
yeah but I I I I regret that we were
offbeat on that song
I feel like the song would actually be
more iconic if if it had been more if we
nailed it yeah yeah this is how well I
know you guys it did not bother me but I
was bothered for you and as we were
watching it I was like definitely these
guys are watching us
because I knew ahead of time because I
remembered the trauma of being like we
didn't nail the rhythm of the thing but
uh well I think we nailed the rhythm of
the podcast I do too I did too
drop a beat for us you ready
[Music]
yes